mezzo o no ma nessuno io sono amico io
sono vitale e oggi a grandissima
richiesta il continuo dell'asl i'm color
giallo
oggi abbiamo slime sirena
manco un ricordo che facciamo dovremo
bendarci ogni turno per stare un
ingrediente e abbiamo qua tutti
ingredienti al tema sirena e a tema
unico neo alla figlia della challange
attiveremo il nostro claim è piano serbo
più sirena nel mio caso piu unico nel
tuo caso vincere alla challenge sarete
voi a decidere chi vince votando nel
sondaggio qua sopra
qual è la prossima challenge sbloccherà
se anche questo video raggiungere i 37
mila mi piace sembrano progetto prossima
star a lyme sono cose contro
italianissima tutto no contro solo con
sepe rollate con il fumo contro fermato
strateghi stimo non vedo l'ora pedalare
di filmarlo quindi mi raccomando
lasciato un bel mi piace su questo video
per sbloccare la prossima slime colori
gialle non siamo questa challenge vitale
si mangerà tutto lo staff sicuro si sia
trattato dall'americana è un primo run
con maggiore tutto punto con erba macché
tutto quello che vuole e de brasi
mettetevi comodi patatine boss carmelo
punti ben prima 232 un avvio ha preso
questo è una colla aprendo una colla a
chi gli occhi io perché essa e speriamo
che sia un bel colore vediamo problema
perché noi abbiamo dei bellissimi colori
però mischiati non sappiamo come
diventeranno nostre classi bellissimo
diventerà un bellissimo blog certezze
non si mischia con altri colori brutti
l'ultima alla quella trasparenza sarà
proprio rossi che bello non vedo l'ora
di vedere come diventerà ciò è
bellissimo wow
vediamo ora il tuo finiamo mai la colla
viola per nota si è stupenda dobbiamo
mettere un po perché sennò poi dopo
rischiamo di farlo diventare e
cominciamo a mescolarla il bello si è
abbattuta unifor rosa abbiamo cominciato
bene almeno per il team viola democrazia
penso che aprendo la stampa beh almeno
però qualche sono sms colorante al viola
sarebbe dov'è il mio slime unicorno
invece o in celeste e quindi non sarà un
problema perché non slime gialloblù mai
uno shampoo e quindi che devi lavare si
ferma ecco qua il mio shampoo celeste
problemi diventata sembra proprio
l'acqua per la sirena e poi dovremo
vedere la sirena dentro sibella sochi
polverina tale azione respirano sul
tacco non sapeva perché vediamo un po
come diventa questo il viola chiara con
il rosa
[Musica]
il bel abbiamo già un vincitore natale
finita la salle giornate ottenuti
sicuramente saranno sentiti due
bellissimi speriamo che non li rovine a
ci spendiamo a colpi di spazzola sono
pronti via e io posso pescare chiedo a
te no ma solo dove posso pescare
certo le cose sono più dicono se l'è
mister non stupire notte a noi non piace
parola di mister bear e vediamo
diana che si sta perfetta dall'unico
nello slang unicorno invece per scatto
della torta di perline a forma di
pesciolini di questo colore un po
arcobaleno perlato che mi sarebbe ebay
salis con la tabella in una bella
decorazione a mettermi i pesciolini che
carini
mettete bel colore che amo non so come
diventerà come lo slime però e
pesciolini si mangiano la sirena
i pesciolini sono amici della fine di
rendere omaggio per la sirena mangia
neanche entrati in acqua sono scomparsi
non si vedono più perché il colore
troppo forte ma vedremo una volta attivo
magari si vedranno nuovamente miliardi
come diventa in questo avvio
io devo stare molto attento perchè ho
paura di questa cosa qui mi rovina lo
slide un po diventerò opaco o al pride
che dimetto poka poka giusto per dare un
po di un po di colore ma non troppo di
sé ma andiamo a mischiare diventate
tutto viola
perché il mio slam più bello non è vero
[Musica]
mi ha attaccato gesto tremendo delle
decorazioni qua devo riuscire a prendere
il più possibile o presente delle
conoscimenti ora credo sia un bel clip
vediamo e perfetti premio ai muri corno
so why per caso da piccolissime delle
conchiglie intero proprio io no ma stai
attenta quando mattina dopo ti cadono
tutti di aspettare sta traballando il
corpo dei mercatali ho pescato questi
glister violetti che provo bellini e che
sono perfetti per il mio slime vediamo
un po come si stanno ecco qua qua razze
più belle queste cuffie o no è caduta
contrario parla adesso che belle le
zucchine uno slam sire rose poi ho preso
tante cose
speriamo che si vedono anche una volta
mischiate ma soprattutto speriamo la
pozzi perché puzza di pesce ma che belle
e mi cade di piena e adesso farà anche
l'umore del tuo slime sv diamanti metodo
per calcolare troppo fa perché sono
andate sott'acqua
ah beh sì è vero perché non vota tv si
veda viviamo è il tuo non visti
bellistri gre basta perché sono poi sono
forti tendiamo a girare e allora è un
ritorno sono in fuga ne è un mocassino
beh sì un pochettino e tu menti per ben
391 stazioni corroso bene ma siamo
pronti
sì o no perché ho preso questo
bottiglione aggrada grande anche se
color rosa però so benissimo di si
tratta di un charm magnus calabrese di
glitter sicuramente speriamo che almeno
migliori colori
volevo io sarebbe il mio blu bordo scuri
centro e tu hai rosa musicante vero che
non vado a rovinare il mio slime che poi
dopo non riesco più ad attivarlo feriamo
ecco qua il pigmento mattino poco
ecco quanto detto così speriamo che
abbia un tono metallizzato per lato ma
chi non rovini il colore vediamo foglia
ovest del progetto cina per futuri non
ha modificato molto il colore più scuro
forse ma non è diventato viola scuro
bene
meno male di altri diventa grave
devo ammettere poco poco è diventato
quindi c'è già tanta schiuma para dei
beni scoppiettanti sicuramente leo bene
lo vedo un pò liquidino ma anche il
penultimo turno
stiamo prontissimo 3 2 1 b ha forse
toccato portiamo questo avevo preso una
buccia di qualcosa la legge prende
questo chiedo anch'io presidente è
troppo bello mi stanno benissimo il bio
imprese kicker blu e tu celesti del
numero mia ne facciamo cambio allora
rogna ma perché non puoi mai fare cambi
scusa tu c'hai viola il socialista ci
scambiamo molte più risalta di più nel
mio blu il blu l'orizzonte è bene
abbiamo blu ma il celeste non risolta
nel mio non vuoi fare cambi
ecco quelli l'iter viola speriamo che lo
rendono ancora più carino li mette tutti
quanti
questo slime sede rossonera
andiamo a girare vediamo un po così è
ancora più stile noto con i glitter
viola che bello siamo un po che di
twitter blu come diventa mai basta non
troppo perché sono cose buone per
offrire gli strumenti nostri trend sono
in contrario adesso il mio brucoli
ginsberg il tool e viola con i glitter
blu blu con i glitter verdini mi ha
detto baby deve essere la maledizione
del verde che integra qui e se lo vuoi e
qui la grande addio che con l'altro io
vorrei sapere come mai il verde stata la
mia parte e il verde non è un colore
unicorn noto invece sticky un colore
miccoli sta bene lo ricordo non ricordo
che bruca l'erba verde direbbe inserire
nicola invece mattina erano tutto niente
è uno stampo questo casino che la sirena
mangione anche del mare ha deciso
hanno votato tutti i mille a star fuori
grazie periodicamente aver indetto non
può negarlo perrotta perché il mio non
fa niente per il verde tu lo vuoi
pescare tester che il trend del verde
per l'ultimo turno vero abbiamo dato la
sirena mazzarelle alti del mare libri
che ricorda come la vecchietta colorata
perché credeva che canta rosa fi
arcobaleno l'accesso al coppa len ove di
cosa hai bisogno delle altre
prossimo turno ha detto meno male un po
perché avevo davvero pescato il burden
siamo un'altra cosa e io ho preso uno
ritorna la lavorazione che io ma solo
uno dei preti l'uno ho toccato e uno lo
crede di prendere di più da quando 21 ma
stai guardando
è una cosa bella di questa prendere più
di una mano devi portare non preso solo
un anno metterlo solo una io invece ho
preso la colla trasparente celeste della
helbers che ci stanno molto bene devo
dire in tutto il resto è diventato il
tuo sito
ecco come lo ammetto la mia con la
trasparente più bella è proprio unico
rosa anche se se guardate bene potete
notare che ci sono dei glitter birdie ma
scusami eh perché metti la quale unico
rosa nel tuo slide quella collera per me
perché nel paesaggio lunare meno tu
dovevi prendono il verde guarda che
linee di qua non dovevi per il verde che
bello è diventato un bel blu pieno di
glitter peccato spero che queste
decorazioni si vedano una volta allora
la mia decorazione che amino qui ho
deciso di metterlo alla fine una volta
attivato lo metto sopra perché non
voglio fare un bello slime di anita
tutte le quali canali che stanno
affogando nello slideshow
ma gli altri pesciolini che lo metterò
sono alla fine sopra lo slime per non
fare soffrire il povero ritornino anche
i ragazzi abbiamo messo tutti in otto
ingredienti quindi ora è arrivato il
momento di attivare la dimora poi potete
portare chivu
siete pronti 3 2 dai più quei news live
sireneuse è un sito un colore super
carino un celeste molto intenso poi si
vedono tutti glitter la consistenza e
molto morbida e ho tolto le code di
siena perché le voglio mettere dopo
perché è un po scomodo da mischiare da
ogni ora
e ora prima di veder code di stile navy
faccio sentire un po di suoni smr
[Musica]
quindi questo il mio slime sireneuse ora
andiamo a mettere le cose di sirena e le
conigliette volontà
da da da
le conchiglie tata ecco finita
il mio slime stir e rosa
vediamo ora quello digitale se mi batte
guardate quanto è bello
sì certo ma devo andare a metà con
quello sahin sirene stupendolo il pilota
è fantastico sentiamo i rumori state
bollicine scoppiettanti vi di persone ha
sicuramente già vinto vitale è vero poi
guardate che bello non è super superò
elastico perché mi sa che lo stimato
purtroppo però dai guardate che karima
super lilla con tutti i glitter blu i
glitter più grandi che sono rosa
stupendo un po che in pochissime parole
davvero il più bello e vince vitale è
vero quindi adesso vado a mettere la
decorazione finale che era il mio ultimo
ingrediente e lo metto proprio vediamo
un po votate chi vince slime asti
renault zoe slime un ritorno
allora guardate il vincitore gesto dal
cioccolato e vinco io servizio vitale mi
raccomando lasciate mi piace per
sbloccare la prossima challenge ma
decente sapere nei commenti quali sono
le altre challenge che potete vedere nel
nostro cantone vi lasciamo con 4 a
casellina pubblicare i nostri altri
video cliccate su quella che preferite e
buona visione
[Musica]